I
our third panel is chaired by dr. Burton
Folsom he is a native of Lincoln
Nebraska and received his PhD from the
University of Pittsburgh he's written
six books including myth of the robber
barons now in its sixth edition this
year he co-authored a seventh book FDR
goes to war which has just been released
by Simon & Schuster FDR goes to war is a
sequel to his best-selling book new
dealer audio which came out in 2008 new
deal or raw deal has had an impact on
the thinking in this country in part
because of Hillsdale colleges new kirby
center for constitutional studies in
washington DC in 2008 the kirby center
sponsored a lecture by burt to leaders
in the media from radio television and
newspaper during that lecture bert read
the quote from FDR's secretary of the
Treasury henry morgenthau 1939 and
Morgenthau was referring to government
spending on so-called stimulus projects
and Morgenthau said we have tried
spending money and it does not work
because of the exposure that the kirby
center could give burt's lecture and
this was just a few weeks after the book
originally came out within a matter of
days that quote was on programs and in
print all over the country soon a
librarian at the Library of Congress
call Burt to ask the specific location
of the quote because they were swamped
with phone calls asking for the citation
Burt referred them to the FDR
Presidential Library in Hyde Park New
York because that quote is in Henry
Morgenthau papers and he made it in a
committee meeting with the leader of the
House Ways and Means Committee and quite
another other politicians of the day and
Morgenthau diary and private papers are
at the FDR library on microfilm bird has
posted a link to the Morgenthau papers
with that quote on his website at Burt
Folsom com along with many other aspects
of World War
now is the new book FDR goes to war it
covers the relationship between franklin
roosevelt and organized labor during
World War two so this is a very timely
for the topic of this panel which is the
debate over public sector unions please
welcome Burt Folsom
Thank You Anita and she of course was my
co-author with FDR goes to war she wrote
half the book and was a big help you
know I wrote this big tax chapter I was
so proud because of it because it was
showing how franklin roosevelt had
raised the income tax after withholding
after f we introduced withholding in
1943 the tax rate on millionaires was up
to one person earning 1 million dollars
had to pay a tax of 1 million six
thousand seven hundred and fifty dollars
which is why more optimistic that some
of our previous speakers because we
certainly have improved from that point
and i think we can today when I had that
chapter though I showed it to Anita and
I was thinking she'd be all impressed at
least I was hoping is my co-author and
she very gently said I think we can do
without the first five pages and I was
shocked and I was even more shocked to
discover that we could and did she had
it starting at exactly the right point
in saying the right thing so I thank
Anita for that and for the introduction
and for the insight into why when you
have academic speakers up here giving
speeches you have to have time limits or
they might go over the limit in case you
wonder where Anita might have gotten
that wild concept that something like
that might happen I might just refer you
to our marriage of 32 years but we have
a great session today on public sector
unions and I'm excited to be chairman of
the panel and introducing as our first
speaker i will introduce some
individually is our first speaker a
colleague of mine at Hillsdale College
in the history department Paul Marino
and Paul Marino is the William and
Bernice grew [ __ ] chair in the American
Constitution and he's the Dean of
Faculty also at Hillsdale College he
earned his doctorate under Herman bells
at the University of Maryland in 1994
Paul has written two books the first
from direct action to affirmative action
fair employment law in Palo
see in America his second book which
I've read and is a great book black
Americans an organized labor a new
history both of these books published by
LSU press Paul has written on labor
history for the wall street journal as
well as for many other professional
journals how many of you in fact saw
Paul's op-ed Monday in the Wall Street
Journal I see a lot of you you might
google it it was one of the most
referred to articles that came out this
week and it's on franklin roosevelt and
how he demonized business and used that
politically and of course making some
parallels for that for today Paul had
that article in The Wall Street Journal
Monday he made an appearance on Fox News
on Tuesday and discussed it before a
larger audience there it was an
excellent presentation that they showed
pictures of Roosevelt and smiling and
business being taxed heavily and it was
it was neck an excellent presentation
Paul has taught at Hillsdale College for
12 years he's held visiting
professorships at Princeton University
and the University of Paris School of
Law Paul and his wife Lisa have four
children and by the way they're
excellent bridge players let me play
please welcome Paul Marino
thank you very much birth that was
wonderful that I am a very mediocre
bridge player I wish I were excellent
thank you I'd like to thank hillsdale
college and the Acton Institute and the
council for Christian colleges and
universities it's a great pleasure to be
here and people to talk to you today and
in addition to our web audience public
sector union ISM represents the third
period in the history of organized labor
in America publicly unions I have
recently things in 2010 overtaken
private unions in total membership
private unions only became a major force
in the American economy with the
National Labor Relations Act or the
Wagner Act of 1935 before that most
employment in America was completely at
will or individual or voluntary I have
some background of these earlier earlier
periods in my full paper but to save
time I'd like to get to the post Wagner
Act period and the public sector union
part of the story more directly but
first about the Wagner Act in a nutshell
what the Wagner Act did was required
employers to bargain collectively with
any organization chosen by a majority of
their employees these are the basic
principles of the Act compulsory
unionism and majority unionism it was an
unabashedly pro-union measure but
outlawed a host of unfair labor
practices by employers but none by
unions although the taft-hartley Act of
1947 tried to restore some balance to
the law it still remained I'd still
maintained the compulsory and majority
principles of the Wagner Act the most
important change that the taft-hartley
Act made was section 14 B which allowed
states to enact what are called
right-to-work laws and over the course
of time industries relocated from Wagner
Act or union shop states to
right-to-work states even more than the
competition of right-to-work states the
rise of global competition in the late
20th century is the principal reason for
the decline of private-sector unionism
quite simply they priced themselves out
of the market or kill the goose that
laid the golden eggs and today we find
that private sector unions are back to
the level that they were about a hundred
years ago less than ten percent of the
private sector workforce now section 2
of the Wagner Act explicitly exempted
public employees from its coverage
Congress declared that the United States
states and political subdivisions of
states were not employers under the
terms of the Act many of you may be
familiar with the letter the President
Roosevelt wrote to the president of the
federation of federal employees in 1937
in which he explained why this must be
Roosevelt said all government employees
should realize that the process of
collective bargaining as usually
understood cannot be transplanted into
the public service it has its distinct
and insurmountable limitations when
applied to public Personnel Management
the very nature and purposes of
government make it impossible for
administrative officials to represent
fully or to bind the employer in mutual
discussions with government employee
organizations the employer is the whole
people who speak by means of laws
enacted by their representatives in
Congress accordingly administrative
officials and employees alike are
governed and guided and in many
instances restricted by laws which
establish policies procedures or rule in
personnel matters now the crucial phase
phrases that Roosevelt uses are the very
nature and purposes of government and
his definition of the employer as the
whole people which speaks by means of
laws that is to say the government is
sovereign and this is the fundamental
difference between public sector and
private sector unionism public unions
began much as private unions did as
voluntary associations that tried to
improve the working conditions of their
members a century ago they were
especially prominent among postal
workers since the post office was one of
the few large-scale federal services in
the first decade of the 20th century
presidents Theodore Roosevelt and
William Howard Taft recognized the
danger of these federal employee
organizations lobbying Congress and
issued executive orders prohibiting
federal employee membership in such
organizations organized labor leaders
and historians have condemned these
orders as gag rules and limitations on
free speech but Theodore Roosevelt was
hardly a reactionary and consider what
another prominent progressive justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes said when he
upheld a Massachusetts law the
prohibited police officers from
soliciting contributions to pull it
organisations home said the petitioner
may have a constitutional right to talk
politics but he has no constitutional
right to be a policeman Congress
overturned these executive orders in the
nineteen twelve Lloyd la follette act
notably the lafalot in this case was
Senator Robert La Follette of Wisconsin
and Wisconsin was the seedbed as many
progressive initiatives and that of
Union empowerment especially as well see
Wisconsin became the first state to
promote public employee unions but this
was this order or this law was limited
only the post office employees it did
not established collective bargaining or
the right to strike but merely the
freedom to petition Congress and there
was no significant extension of federal
employee organization rights until the
1960s the decisive episode in public
sector union ISM was the 1919 Boston
Police Frank the public reaction to this
strike probably set back public sector
union ISM several decades no public
serve is better underscored the
sovereign nature of government than the
police the federal equivalent would be
to allow the soldiers and sailors of the
army or Navy to form unions and this is
not as far-fetched as it sounds as
Norway and Germany today allow army
unions we might have avoided World War
two if that had been mandated in the
Treaty of Versailles this strike made a
national hero of Calvin Coolidge who
succinctly explained that there is no
right to strike against the public
safety by anybody anywhere anytime
president woodrow wilson also called the
strike an intolerable crime against
civilization today the American left is
chagrin that Liberal Democrats like
Governor Andrew Cuomo of New York have
taken stock tough stands against state
employee unions but this is nothing new
mayor fiorello laguardia of New York
City did the same in the 1940s when the
city took over the subways and
twenty-six thousand members of the
Transport Workers Union became public
employees Mayor John Lindsay later took
a similar stance in the 1970s until new
york governor nelson rockefeller
undercut him by the 1950s public opinion
had become more open to the prospect of
public labor unions private sector
unions began to decline in relative
terms in the mid-1950s and they
become much less radical less prone to
strike and less prone to violence when
they did strike the expansion of
business in the right-to-work states of
the south and the West made union
leaders more cautious above all there
was tremendous growth in the public
sector workforce nearly 9 million by
nineteen sixty two or one out of every
eight workers in the country this
proportion would reach nearly one in
five or eighteen percent by 1970 the
American Federation of State County
immunised and municipal employee has led
the effort to get a state to allow
public employee union ization this is
absentee they originated originated in
Wisconsin and Wisconsin took the lead in
pro union legislation New York City
actually preceded Wisconsin with similar
legislation in 1958 and many other
states and cities followed the federal
government followed when President
Kennedy signed executive order 10 9 8 8
in 1962 this order permitted federal
employees to form unions and bargain
collectively though it did not grant the
right to bargain over wages which
remained under Congress's control or the
right strike unions these unions also
could not compel federal employees to
join and they again they cannot strike
this order was strengthened by President
Nixon and finally given a statutory
basis by Congress in the Civil Service
Act of 1978 with these new federal and
state policies in place the numbers of
Public Employee members swelled rapidly
from 400,000 to 4 million by 1970 this
was largely because many public
employees were already organized old
professional associations simply became
labor unions the National Education
Association for example had been formed
in 1857 as the National Teachers
Association it had regarded itself as a
professional association much like the
American Bar Association or the American
Medical Association but when it faced
the trade unionism of the American
Federation of Teachers afl-cio it had to
convert to a union or die and the NEA
today is the largest labor union in the
United States but it still remains
unaffiliated with the afl-cio when the
Wagner Act promoted private sector
unionization in the 1930s the principle
justification for the Act was that
would promote industrial peace and
facilitate interstate commerce it
actually had the opposite effect
producing more strikes and greater labor
militancy in the nineteen thirty-seven
state and federal encouragement of
public sector bargaining had a similar
and even greater impact unprecedented
strikes by teachers garbage collectors
postal workers and others became common
in the late 1960s and 1970s despite the
fact that every state prohibited strikes
by public employees the issue reached
the crisis point in the mid-to-late
1970s ask me push Congress to force all
the states to recognize public employee
unions and to give public employee
unions even greater powers than private
sector unions enjoy the post was for
what was called a National Public
Employment Relations law which was
called a Wagner Act for public employees
and this effort was led by
representative William clay of Missouri
his son William clay jr. holds the same
seat in Congress today while the
prospects for public employee union ISM
seem bright there were also foreboding
signs askme had begun to arouse
resentment from other union federations
the afl-cio and the Service Employees
International Union especially Abby's
president a man named Jerry worth was
notably abrasive and became an easy
target for his opponents he said for
example the police and firefighter union
should let our cities burn if they
didn't get what they demanded and this
phrase became the title of a book by
ralph de toledano but most of all the
disruptive and illegal strikes of the
period like the sit-down strikes of the
night of the 1930s began to turn public
opinion against public unions the
Supreme Court began to get cold feet
about this matter of public employee
union is a shin in march of 1976 it
decided to congress could not extend the
Fair Labor Standards Act to state
employees just as Harry Blackmun a
recent Nixon appointee was the swing
vote in this five-to-four decision for
the first time since the New Deal the
court had recognized the limit on
Congress's power to regulate interstate
commerce the Court recognized the fact
that quote the states as states stand on
a quite different footing from an
individual
work or a corporation this decision its
title as the National League of Cities
versus usury took the wind out of the
sails of public employee union ism it
may have prevented the United States
from going the way of Great Britain or
Italy in the late 1970s and one of the
reasons why this decision was so
important was that it preserved the the
principle that's often referred to as
competitive federalism it was very much
like section 14 B of the taft-hartley
Act which permitted States to prohibit
compulsory private sector unionism that
enabled employers in to move from union
shop states like New York or Michigan to
open shop or right-to-work states like
Texas or Georgia but if the government
of New York State or New York City faces
costly public sector unions those
governments can't just move to Texas but
their taxpaying residents can and the
National Public Employees relation Act
would have made this impossible and
imported New York style public sector
union ISM to the entire country and the
Supreme Court decision made that
impossible the reaction to the cost of
public unions help revive of
conservative movements in the 1970s and
1980s electing Margaret Thatcher in 1979
in Britain and Ronald Reagan year in
1980 the defeat of the National Public
Employment Relations Act was decisive
but since it involved complicated and
technical legislative and judicial
doctrines and maneuvers it was
overshadowed by the dramatic
confrontation of Ronald Reagan and the
air traffic controllers in 1981 ironies
abound in this episode Reagan had been
not only a union member but the
president of the Screen Actors Guild he
had also signed California's 1968 law
permitting public employee union is a
shin the professional air traffic
controllers a patco they're called had
endorsed Reagan in the nineteen eighty
election but when their demands were not
met the Union decided to play hardball
they took the advice of Representative
clay who made the following statement to
the 1980 patco convention clay told them
your plan must must be one which
completely revises your political
thinking it should start with the
premise that you have no permanent
friends no permanent enemies just
permanent interests
it must be selfish and pragmatic you
must learn the rules of the game and
learn them well rule number one says
that you don't put the interest of any
other group ahead of your own what's
good for the federal employees must be
interpreted as being good for the nation
rule number two says that you take what
you can and you give up only what you
must rule number three says that you
take it from whomever you can whenever
you can however you can if you are not
prepared to play by these rules of the
game then you have not reached the age
of political maturity the title of this
conference is markets government and the
common good and there isn't much of a
sense of the common good in these
comments by representative clay we might
call this the malian dialogue of the
patco strike it exposed just the the
utter selfishness of public employee
unions and it makes it easy to
understand why Reagan was able to take
the strong stand that he did by firing
and replacing the striking air traffic
controllers and why the publicly
overwhelmingly supported him in this the
patco strike is invariably depicted as a
replay of the 1919 Boston Police fright
Reagan after all had taken down FDR's
portrait in the Oval Office and replaced
it with one of Calvin Coolidge patco the
interpretation usually goes was the
opening salvo of the Republicans
campaign to repeal the New Deal
destroying organized labor in order to
redistribute income from Main Street to
Wall Street etc etc but breaking the
patco strike had approximately zero
impact on public sector union ism it may
have cooled public unionists willingness
to strike but their numbers continued to
flourish in 1980s state employment grew
twenty percent or twice the rate of the
population the number of public employee
union members has grown over twenty-five
percent in the last 25 years keeping
pace with the growth of population and
becoming a majority as I said of all
union members last year the patco
replacement workers soon joined a new
Union the national air traffic
controllers Association which carried on
Pat ko's work the failure to reverse
public sector union ism indeed the
failure even to attempt it is another
indication of how limited the impact of
the so-called Reagan
revolution was in domestic affairs but
it's also often said that Reagan's
breaking of the patco strike sent a
signal to private sector employers that
it was now acceptable to take a hard
line against their unions but this is
also very doubtful the factor is
responsible for private sector union
decline long antedated the patco strike
and continued after it I would even
argue that Reagan actually helped the
public employee union movement by
reviving the private sector economy he
caused public opinion to lose concern
about the issue public unions do well
and flush times thus their rapid growth
in the 1950s and 1960s when the public
thinks that they can absorb the other
costs and they become unpopular when
taxpayers begin to feel the cost of them
as in the 1970s and today but during the
flush times they add to the cost of
government the government at all levels
consumed only thirteen percent of GDP in
1929 that rose to thirty three percent
in 1960 and about forty five percent by
the mid-1990s and we may now face the
time when the time may have come when it
will be impossible to revive the private
economy to absorb the costs of public
sector unions can this leads to another
point that defenders of public unions
often deny that union negotiated wages
and benefits even tensions are
responsible for the tremendous state and
federal debt and deficits that we were
talking about this morning but the
direct costs of public employee unions
are only the tip of the iceberg consider
for example the decline in the quality
of education along with its increased
costs since unionization the subject of
our last panel public employee unions do
not simply lobby for greater benefits
for their own members but for the
expansion of government on all levels
was there any greater supporter of
President Obama and Obamacare than the
public employee unions when the health
care industry is fully nationalized it
will add some fifteen percent of the
government share of GDP actually
somewhat less than that since the
industry is already half nationalized by
way of Medicare and Medicaid and once
the federal government is the employer
it will be that much easier to organize
the unorganized healthcare workers
anyway that's the the background or the
history of a public sector employee
unionism but I think it's fairly obvious
from a constitutional point that this
situation can't go on forever if the
United States is going to remain a
constitutional republic as FDR himself
recognized the fundamental question in
the debate over public sector union ism
is the question of sovereignty of the
really who's going to control the
government's FDR recognize if there's a
public sector union that is compelling
the government to bargain then that
union must be the sovereign power itself
and I think if you look at the the
looming anarchy that we see in Greece
today that is the logical outcome or
logical result of the kind of
anarcho-syndicalism that is really built
into the the ideology of unionism and
public sector union ISM especially thank
thank you Paul that's refreshing to hear
of it Teddy Roosevelt Taft Coolidge even
Woodrow Wilson and FDR spoke strongly
strongly opposed public sector union ism
thanks for that talk on the history of
public sector union is mark our next
speaker is Chuck Baird whose talk will
be on the political economy of
government sector unionism and Chuck
received his PhD from the University of
California at Berkeley in 1968 Chuck
says he spent the next five years on the
faculty at UCLA really learning
economics from his colleague Armand al
Kian he was professor of economics at
California State University at eastbay
from 1973 until his retirement in 2007
he has been a visiting professor at
Stanford University and also at
universities in South Africa and in
Guatemala Chuck is a member of the mont
pelerin society and he has served there
as vice president and also as a member
of the board of directors he is a
quarterly columnist that is four times a
year for the magazine The Freeman and
the Freeman of course elevates free
market principles and is published by
the foundation for economic education
Chuck Barrett has published four text
books all of which went into a second
edition that's important because it just
wasn't his students having to buy the
book
other professors also like the books and
sent them into second edition Chuck has
published 9 Public Policy monographs
over 90 articles in various journals and
magazines his research specialty is in
law and economics of labor relations he
is also written on environmentalism the
tax system and the Austrian School of
Economics please welcome Chuck bear
well thank you Bert for that very kind
introduction the as you see on the
screen I just that's the last time I'm
going to turn because now I know what's
up there so I can just look at this one
my title is the political economy of
government sector unionism
notwithstanding that my assignment was
to talk about the economics of public
sector union ism so I need to explain
why i'm talking about political economy
politics and economics are simply
inextricably entwined in government
sector unionism as justice Lewis Powell
observed in the Abboud case Abboud vs
Detroit Board of Education in 1977 he
says the ultimate objective of a union
in the public sector like that of a
political party is to influence public
decision making in accordance with the
views and perceived interests of its
membership and so on and then that last
sentence in the second paragraph
collective bargaining and the public
sector is political in any meaningful
sense of the term you simply cannot
separate politics and economics when it
comes to government sector unionism now
why do I say government sector unionism
instead of public sector union is and
well because I remember that Milton
Friedman always admonished people to
talk about government schools rather
than public schools so following that
lead which is always a good lead to
follow it is government sector not
public sector unions I think that there
is more appropriate label for them and
they are government employees not public
employees and much less is it reasonable
to talk about most of them as public
servants so I have an acronym for
government employee unions goo
and the plural goos which i will use in
my remarks to come but let's look at
some tables all my data from these
tables behind these tables come from a
website called Union Union stats com
available at the click at a simple click
the charts aren't there but the data are
there and of course I generated these
charts using Excel so you can see the
top line there is government union
density from 1983 to 2010 what are what
do I mean by density it's the percent of
in this case government workers all
three levels excluding the post office
post office employees are not included
in this data but it's the percent of
government employees all three levels of
government who are government union
members that's what density is the
percent of workers who are government
union members now we'll see a little bit
later that it's not just government
union members who fall under the the
coercion of government sector collective
bargaining because there are a lot of
people who are forced to accept the
representation services of government
unions who have simply chosen not to be
members but I'll get to that point a
little bit later and we can see in this
chart that government sector unionism
sensor 1983 in 1983 is the first date
where they began to build a consistent
data set on Union densities both private
and government so the government density
has fluctuated between 35 and 40 you the
bottom line is the private sector
union density and that has been steadily
declining since 1983 actually it's been
declining for longer than that because
the peak was around the mid-1950s that
thirty-five percent but it has been
steadily falling ever since and in 2010
the last year for which we have data six
point nine percent of private-sector
workers were union members only six
point nine percent that's roughly what
the private sector union density was
prior to the adoption of the National
Labor Relations Act in 1935 so as we
cast about for something about which to
be optimistic there's one for you now I
just aggregated the government figures
into out local which is the top yellow
line you see local government employees
we're talking primarily public's
government school teachers sorry see
government school teachers firefighters
and cops mainly there are others but
those are the three big groups that's
that's fluctuated between 40 and 45
percent over that time interval state
employees like state university
employees which I used to beat that kind
of animal and also I'm getting quite a
pension for having done that for having
put up with such excruciating pain but
as state employees over that interval
density thirty percent give or take and
then the bottom one is federal civilian
employees the military aren't union
heights that all thank God for that
excluding the post office and that has
been fluctuating between twenty and
fifteen percent over that period of time
so you see the only area in which there
is any
kline in unionism is the private sector
and the reason for that of course is
that the private sector in the private
sector employers have to face
competition and they can't afford to
take cost increases give wage increases
that have the effect of raising unit
labor costs and simply absorb it they
can't pass it forward to consumers
because of because of competition and
the profit margins are already low
enough because of competition so there's
a big well-founded well-reasoned
resistant resistance amongst employers
to unionization in the private sector
that's not true in the government sector
as we'll see in a minute now this is how
this that statistic has already been
alluded to Paul alluded to it this is
the percent of all union workers
government and private who are
government union workers and notice in
2000 is starting in 2009 but for both
2009 in 2010 that's over fifty percent
the the union movement and by the way it
is a union movement not a labor movement
labour is a much bigger set than union
workers in in in 2010 that figure was
fifty two percent and we'll see what
percent rate is when the data come out
and that will be in January for 2011 now
I referred earlier to this difference
between the percent of workers who are
members that's that bottom red area as
opposed to that top line the percent of
government workers who are covered by
collective bargaining agreements with
government unions
there's a difference there and you can
see it's a rather large difference over
time although it seems to be narrowing I
take that as a as one indication at
extent to which government is employ is
is violating workers freedom of
association in principle I have no
objection especially in the private
sector to any private worker who wants
to be a union member being a union
member i can't object to that and if an
employer wants the bargain with the
union who is represented who is
representing a number of voluntary
employees so be it's none of my business
but the whole principle the key
principle of the Wagner Act section 9 a
of the Wagner Act exclusive
representation there's an election and a
50-percent plus one vote to unionize
then all of the workers will be
bargained for by that winning union not
just the members all of them it's winner
take all monopoly bargaining and that
blue area represents that a very
important difference i'm working on
forced association i'm doing a paper for
the upcoming a p conference in las vegas
in april and so i become very interested
in this question of forced association
now I want to go quickly through a
public choice analysis of government
employee unions basic principle of
public choice analysis is that he can
get away with a whole lot when there are
focused benefits and diffused costs
during the Wisconsin brouhaha earlier
this year we were treated to the
spectacle of government employees saying
raise my taxes right and people would
say well gee why would they say that
well it's obvious because sure they're
paying taxes along with everybody else
but they get back a hugely
disproportionate set of benefits
Gordon taluk and illustrated this by his
favorite law which which is this
supposes the law passed imposing a one
dollar a year per person Tulloch tax on
everybody and that the proceeds of the
tullett tax returned over to taluk boy
color would love that right and a dollar
a year now who cares Gordon's are pretty
nice guy so you might say who cares and
even people who don't know it's it's de
minimis too much to worry about but
that's focusing benefits on the relative
few at the expense of a great many but
on a per person basis those costs are
low a couple of other principles are
important in in this consideration
rational abstention why why did why is
the participation rate in elections
lower than a lot of people to like it to
be well consider what the benefits are a
voting what benefit is that to me of
casting a vote if it doesn't change the
outcome may make me feel good my civic
duty but it's a very small benefit if I
can't change the outcome and what's the
probability that i can change the
outcome my one vote in significantly
different from zero so the benefits of
voting appear to be very small but their
costs are very real you have to register
you have to queue up you have to use
gasoline or a potion stand next to the
benefits those costs are huge and so a
lot of people rationally choose to
abstain from voting but as I say civic
duties sometimes overcomes that people's
view of what the civic duty is sometimes
will overcome that but then there's
another problem and that's rational
ignorance
a lot of people cast uninformed votes
they don't pay attention why because
their vote doesn't affect the outcome
unless that causes a tie or breaks a tie
and again the probability of that the
ex-ante probability of that is
negligible but it costs a lot to become
informed you have to pay attention you
have to weigh the pros and cons of the
various tissues and candidates why
bother instead why not just toss a coin
in deciding how to vote rather than
taking on the cost of becoming informed
when you buy a new car you're very
careful about that car because your
decision determines the outcome when you
vote you're less careful because your
decision does not determine the outcome
on the other hand organized interests
about whom I will have much to say just
now have a keen incentive to vote indeed
they go door to door pull people out
tell them to vote early and often and
work work very hard to get their way now
there isn't public choice what is called
the Iron Triangle model I have to
quickly go over this there are
politicians there are special interest
groups like unions and there are
bureaucrats or government employees
there's an exchange between politicians
and special interest groups politicians
want to get elected and stay elected
special interest groups want rents they
want favors from the politicians and so
they enter into that very comfortable
exchange there's another exchange
between politicians and government
employees government employees want
bigger budgets more perks more power and
so what's their exchange with the
politicians while a politician's say to
the government deploy ease will pad your
budgets and in exchange you keep our
special interest groups happy okay
there's a an iron triangle for each
special interest group but look with
government employee unions what
the Iron Triangle become the government
employees and the interest groups are
they converged they are the GE use the
goos and they form the Iron Triangle
collapses into the handle of an iron
dagger as I would say with the taxpayers
on the outside of the process who have
to pay the bills and here comes the
dagger sorry for that now force campaign
contributions is another issue
government sector pay comes from all
taxpayers some of that pay is taken from
government employees for union dues gu
bosses spend large portions of union
dues to elect big government politicians
so all taxpayers even those who favor
small government are forced to support
big government politicians the hair dye
Jim shirk at the Heritage Foundation
sorry Oh Hillsdale graduate okay that
must have been Larry right yeah right
Jim shark put this together this chart
showing the importance of contributions
and special interest groups to keep the
politicians happy three of the five top
in 209 at the ten election cycle where
the american federation of state
government and municipal municipal
employees the service employees the
notorious Service Employees
International and of course every the
one that everybody loves especially if
you have children in school the National
Education Association now very quickly
here the power of monopoly is a big is
is is a big reason why government
employee unions are much more successful
than private sector unions government
agencies do not have to compete with
private sector
providers therefore cost increases due
to government sector collective
bargaining can be pushed forward to the
customers who are the customers the
taxpayers is not legal to refuse to pay
in the private sector we as customers
have all kinds of alternatives we can go
to alternative suppliers we can decide
not to buy at all and therefore in the
private sector there really are two
sides that to the collective bargaining
table the the private sector employers
playing with his own money he's got his
residual claim at stake there is a
contrary interest on the other side and
they work it out but in the government
sector and the government sector there
are no two sides to the collective
bargaining table they're on the same
side they have a common interest and
that is to pick the pocket of taxpayers
now there are a couple of empirical
studies I want to cite here Chris
Edwards at Cato in the Cato journal
winter 2010 finds that the state and
local compensation exceeds comparable
private sector compensation by forty
five percent Jim shirk again finds it
for federal compensation the margin is
thirty to forty percent and look at this
how about job security right this is the
layoffs and discharges as the percent of
total employment that's the power of
monopoly when you don't have to face
competition and lastly I see my time is
running out here James Otis is famous
here's a cloning of Massachusetts
politician is famous for coining the
term at least in the United States or in
the colonies taxation without
representation is tyranny and that gave
rise to the Boston Tea Party of 1773
taxes indeed are supposed to be decided
by elected legislators and elected
executives it's supposed the process is
supposed to be open but
taxpayers are not represented at the
government sector collective bargaining
table the bureaucrats sitting across the
table from the from the goose do not
represent taxpayers they have a common
interest to pick the pockets of
taxpayers for bigger budgets more life
arranging power more income more and
better perks speaking of which is the
official time the time that you get off
the on pay on the ticket while doing
Union work and a competitive enterprise
institute tells us that that amounted to
in 2009 alone 1 million 129 million one
hundred thousand seven hundred
ninety-eight dollars that seems a little
too precise for an estimate but
nevertheless it gives you the it gives
you the the ballpark and then finally
mandatory good faith bargaining what is
the significance of this when it comes
to government sector unions mandatory
good faith bargaining in the private
sector means the private employer and
the Union must bargain if one wants the
bargain about less it's something
illegal if one wants the bargain about
something the other has to and it has to
be good faith bargaining that means they
have to compromise in the government
sector that means that the government
employee unions get effective veto power
because the other whoever's bargaining
with them must compromise with them
nothing can happen without their
approval so they become an illicit
fourth branch of government and my time
has run out thank you
yeah Thank You Chuck it's good to be
reminded of that incredible growth that
remarkable growth of public sector
unions and if you look at the record of
the private sector unions right they
started most heavily in the late 1930s
with especially in the auto industry
with the UAW but also the steelworkers
union and the rubber Workers Union and
it's not exactly a pleasant history when
you consider that two generations later
the industries which were represented by
those unions were completely run out of
business or at least almost run out of
business here in the United States our
last speaker today is steven greenhut
and he will his topic is the politics of
public sector unions steven greenhut
works for the Pacific Research Institute
there at the Pacific Research Institute
Steven is the director of the journalism
Center which was launched in January of
2010 to provide in-depth news coverage
of California government the journalism
center focuses on uncovering waste fraud
and misuse of taxpayer dollars I repeat
the journalism Center focuses on
uncovering waste fraud and the misuse of
taxpayer dollars actually I just met
Steve before the front
I just met Steve before our panel here
and I asked him did you need to get out
the big microscope to uncover this waste
fraud and misuse of taxpayer dollars and
he assured me it was right there and he
reports it on their website at Cal
watchdog com it's one of the most
influential sites on political news in
California Stephen writes a column for
several newspapers including the Orange
County Register the san francisco
examiner and human events he is a
contributor to City Journal California
and Stephen is the author of two books
in 2004 he wrote his book abuse of power
how the government miss uses eminent
domain his new book is on public sector
unions it is entitled plunder he felt we
needed a subtitle which was how public
employee unions are raiding Treasuries
controlling our lives and bankrupting
the nation seibon graduated from george
washington university and is married and
has three daughters won't you please
welcome steven greenhut
yeah I always say my subtly titled book
plunder in fact one of the editors was
was she was editing it and she found
something she thought would be offensive
i'm like you know if they get that far
in the book and aren't offended you know
i'm not i'm not changing it chuck was
talking earlier about you to the milton
friedman calling his government rather
than public sector which i like our
original publisher at the Orange County
Register went them one better instead of
calling it the public schools or the
government schools he called them the
gun run schools so now I refer to the
force based community whenever I discuss
a public sector well a government
official sits in his office finds a lamp
in an old filing cabinet rubs it in a
genie appears he this genie is mindful
of our 15-minute limit here so the genie
gives only two wishes the first this
government employee wants to be on an
island where beautiful women the real
joke said nymphomaniacs but this is a
nice Christian group so where beautiful
women reside poof he was their second
and final wish I wish I never had to
work again poof he was back in his
government office and so I look well in
reality he could have stayed on at the
island and at least if you were a
California state employee and received
two six-figure costs a living adjusted
pension check for him and the beautiful
woman of his choice until death do they
part there's a new this is for real a
new actuarial term that's called the
viagra effect government employees
especially in the public safety and
remember public safety is this
ever-expanding category it's not just
police fire prison guards it's billboard
expect ears milk inspectors cooks and
prisons you know it's like rust and
never sleeps anyway the retiring so
young and then marrying people who are
that much younger that the actuaries
actually have to take that into account
as they're figuring out this massive
pension debt that we're all stuck paying
for it well there is good news and you
know consider I'm from California so
this is good news we're running out of
money and running out of money focuses
the mind so you know I wrote my piece
that I'm sure will
posted on your regarding this conference
here but as I was flying over here
yesterday I've learned that Governor
Brown was was introducing a new pension
reform so this morning I got up and I
took a look and I i changed it it
actually isn't a bad pension reform
proposal so this governor who was
elected with 30 million dollars
record-setting 30 30 million dollars and
independent expenditures from the public
sector unions and he's done pretty much
everything they wanted although he did
veto a bill that would have unionized
childcare workers babysitters so there's
even too much for him his plan is ok I
don't think it will go anywhere in our
union dominated legislature but the
basic issues are we're running out of
money huge financial problem obviously
here's an issue I like to talk about
it's not fair I mean what why do those
of us who work in the in the private
sector have to retire 20 years later and
with the third of the amount of our
public sector colleagues it's just
that's not a really fair system and one
thing too that's interesting is because
public sector employees are on a defined
contribution system and with the promise
is backed by taxpayers they're really
not they don't care that much about the
ongoing economy because they're not tied
to it if my 401k plan goes up I make
more if it goes down I make less it
doesn't matter if you're a government
employee you you get the same formula no
matter what doesn't matter what the
economy does that's not really healthy I
don't think it kind of makes our public
servants the masters okay it's depleting
public services this is an argument I
make in a blue state like California to
liberals we're stuck dealing with a lot
of liberals who think unions are good
and we just have to make this argument
that you know what it's destroying the
public services you care about we can
argue over how big government should be
another time but do you really think
would you really rather close the park
so that you can pay retired police
captain's who are often Coeur d'Alene
Idaho three hundred thousand dollars a
year okay it's also distorting the
nature of our society public sector
unions provider one-way ratchet for more
government
and and it's also the unions are
distorting accountability a lot of what
I learned on the issue was when I when I
was a columnist at the Orange County
Register covering local government in a
solid Republican County and you know
Orange County obviously and watching it
didn't matter Republicans were were
expanding pensions retro actively the
unions were covering up for for the
worst offenders in their midst so these
these are these are the things that have
to drive change at some point now when i
said before california unions on the
legislature that's not really fair they
are the legislature the Assembly Speaker
John Perez is best known as a united
food and commercial workers organizer
who led the Southern California grocery
strikes and Darrell Steinberg's a form
the Senate Pro Tem is a former SEIU
attorney so they think like unions right
they're not it's not just that they're
beholden to unions they are the Union so
what helped what hope do we have so our
only hope seems to be a very flawed
Progressive Era system known as the
initiative and referendum so in last
November's election there were nine
pension reform initiatives not all of
them they weren't all in conservative
areas and eight of them passed the only
one that did not pass was the one in San
Francisco and that came fairly close and
in San Francisco Jeff Adachi the public
defender who is a progressive Democrat
and actually good good guy he's serious
about reform and he's back again with a
new initiative and of course the city
has has been playing all sorts of games
to try to undermine that initiative he's
also running for mayor of course at San
Francisco he's not going to win neither
is the initiative but it's a good good
good effort okay how bad are things well
according to Stanford University we have
a 500 billion dollar unfunded liability
and you'll find everything dealing with
pensions through these terms that are
meant to make your eyes glaze over
what's an unfunded liability well it's a
debt that's going to have to be paid so
i get from unions a lot they say well
you know it's not a real debt because
you know it's calculated based on rates
of return say okay it's not a real debt
then let's not pay your pensions is not
a real obligation
whoa so they're not really there back
away from that argument fairly quickly
in the city of Vallejo which went
bankrupt and we're probably going to see
more bankruptcies coming down the pike
they were paying police captain total
pan benefit package of three hundred
thousand dollars Vallejo which believe
me needs a police service has been
warning its residents not to use the 911
system judiciously in other words don't
call unless charles manson's at the door
and they cut their pool I'm always
accused of being anti Public Safety well
because of the ridiculous pay and
benefit packages they're the ones who
are cutting the police force by a third
and shutting down fire stations I'm just
not for this kind of abuse so Vallejo is
you know it's a pro now of course
Vallejo the City Council is dominated by
union members it's an old port city so
they went bankrupt and they came out of
it without really touching their
pensions so go figure it's not a
cure-all the hundred thousand dollar
pension club is has 15,000 members and
it's growing by about forty percent each
year that the closer you get the more
recent retirees obviously are retiring
with the with the higher higher amounts
I hear a lot from the well the unions
will always say well the average you
know mr. Greenhut doesn't understand
that the average pension is only twenty
seven thousand dollars well yeah that
goes back you know two people who
retired in the Pleistocene era and who
maybe it's an average it includes
everybody people who have only worked a
short period of time and in recent
retirees the figure somewhere in the 60s
and that's cost-of-living adjusted that
the average retirement package for a
California Highway Patrol who retired in
the last couple years and worked at
least twenty years is ninety eight
thousand dollars so we wonder why
there's a unfunded pension life okay the
disabilities eight according to the
Sacramento Bee that notorious right-wing
newspaper eighty-two percent of the
California Highway Patrol have retired
with a disabling injury miraculously
they discover that their back aches or
irritable bowel syndrome is one of the
most popular ones exactly a year before
retirement and then that protects fifty
percent of the retirement from taxes and
they get an extra year off and I I still
have a standing offer and this only
applies to California if you can find a
police chief in the last ten years who
retired not on a disability I'll buy you
a pretty good lunch and it just doesn't
happen I remember one down at Irvine who
dropped a briefcase on his toe and was
disabled when I when I worked at the
newspaper I help chase a disabled police
officer out of out of state yeah he was
he was applying for other police chief
jobs while he was disabled and he told
me he was disabled only from that one
particular job ok so now Public Safety
and you know I think we need another
term for Public Safety you know because
that just saw everyone who's against
public safety how they retire with three
percent at fifty that's the typical
retirement that means ninety percent of
your final year's pay before all the
pension spiking gimmicks the the be just
had it had a story about how public
employees how government employees state
workers were retiring and then cashing
in their unused vacation and even
sometimes sick leave as much as eight
hundred thousand dollars they take away
most people in the private sector don't
even have savings of that much for their
entire retirement there are all sorts of
double dipping scams air time where you
buy additional retirement for pennies on
the dollar of course the they pay
pennies we pay the dollars that's one of
the things that Governor Brown is
targeting then there are the cancer
presumptions which keeping cancer and
heart attack presumptions if you or I
are you know get cancer or heart attacks
it's assumed in my case to be my life
style of eating donuts and drinking beer
and not exercising if you happen to be a
retired CHP officers presumed to be on
the job related and then that relate
that opens a whole store of benefits
that we get to pay for any way that the
Sacramento Bee again and I like to quote
then they do a good job covering this
issue but they're a liberal paper so i'm
not i'm not getting this this isn't from
the right wing press as i get accused of
but governments have become pension
providers that provide services
on the side what does that say about our
society that's pretty depressing then
there are the this terrible entitlement
mentality that has seeped in I know this
shocks you within the government
employees and I here's a good this is a
great example I wrote about this for the
LA Times the city of Alameda right next
to Oakland a man goes wage into the
water 60 degree water he's going to
commit suicide dozens of police and
firefighters show up they stand around
they watch he drowns they don't go in
and get the body a bystander goes and
gets the body they interview the police
and fire they say well we didn't have
the proper cold water training well you
know I mean I don't want to I don't
usually go swimming in a San Francisco
Bay in 60 degree water but I'm sorry
that's not life threatening and anyway
they interviewed one of the TV stations
interviewed this guy ritchie's on Beck I
think we need to name names whenever
possible he's the division chief of
Alameda and they asked him whether he
would go and save a child who heard
route was drowning in the same situation
and he gave a bureaucratic answer that
was no not if I were on duty but if I
were off duty I'd know what to do well
in my thinking if we're safer with these
guys being off duty than we are with
their being on duty then we ought to
disband all these departments and this
isn't I I've written about this a bit
this is not uncommon as the problem but
I just read the other day that don't
worry about it the city the Alameda fire
department just bought new boats so we
are safe indeed then I love everything
about government is hilarious if it
weren't depressing that the hypocrisy
angle is is just it's just too much to
take I mean as I think I could put up
with the corruption the greed the waste
the unfairness all the horrible things
government does if they just wouldn't
lecture us and pretend that they're
better than us I'll make that deal and
and CalPERS the California Public
Employee Retirement System which is a
journalist I call it the gift that keeps
on giving they assume a rate of return
of 7.75 percent now if I could get a
rate of return of that
I'm just putting my money there and at
least I'll have some semblance of a
retirement and they blast me they have a
whole CalPERS responds and they've
responded to some of my pieces so to
speak and then but when they when they
18 when our money's at stake seven point
seven five percent in other words they
guess that that's the rate of return and
that's how they base the retirement
based on this money coming in at that
rate well a number of localities
especially in Orange County have been
sick of the corruption scandals at
CalPERS and so forth and they went out
at the CalPERS system go into another
system while CalPERS will pay them a
whopping three point eight percent when
its own money's at stake and CalPERS
blast Stanford which used a four point
one percent so you can see the hypocrisy
there and of course there always pay for
place candles they have this diversity
measure that I had a hilarious time with
her basically preaching about diversity
to everybody else well I went and I
linked to my article to their board so
about board diversity on private
companies on being a bald overweight
white guy just you can guess who's on
their board but it's just a matter of
why they're lecturing us about that sort
of thing when they have amazing problems
of their own anyway you know numbers are
on our side I had this debate with this
union official a nice guy and after the
debate and he said well my friend said
you you know you beat me whatever I said
well that's because you're wrong he goes
well I have a tougher side of the
argument well my view if you're getting
the tougher side of the argument then
you're wrong and you ought to change
your argument but that's why I love the
quote from daniel Hannan last night the
Upton Sinclair quote it's very difficult
to get a man to understand something
when his salary is dependent on him not
understanding it and that's the problem
we're going against and that's what we
have to fight against and we also have
to fight against these awful lies that I
know that shocks you unions lying but
and I've seen unions at boards of
Supervisors they promise that so-and-so
retroactive pension increase will not
affect the budget at all won't affect
the budget at all and i have watched
good Republicans say okay and
for that thing as soon as it's voted for
the courts have ruled that's an ironclad
legal promise and then literally on the
last what it was three weeks later we
learned that it increased the unfunded
liability by three hundred million
dollars which is a lot of money in a
county and then anyway but they don't
care they don't care they lied they got
what they want well another lie and this
is the most fun one that I've had
debunking is hear it all the time from
union officials we we die early
especially the public safety once they
say we die three to five years after we
retire that's why we get these enormous
pensions well if that were true I mean
just think about it we wouldn't have a
large unfunded liability problem but and
but as I always say I wish a long and
healthy life for everybody however I
went and did the research and CalPERS
they provided me their data and they
also provided me a report to bunking it
they have good actuarial data they're
not so good on the corporate ethics but
they've got good data and it turns out
that the longest living category of
employee of any type as a police officer
followed closely behind by a firefighter
and they live to be in their mid 80 so
it's not exactly true also I refer to
their whole idea about we're twenty
seven thousand dollars a year it's
nonsense but this criticism they say
escape coating they have a website don't
scapegoat us they being some of the
union activists don't scapegoat us my
mom calls me a couple months ago and she
says Steve you're on television and I'm
like wow what station she MSNBC I'm like
wow I've never been on MSNBC I better
take a look and they had the new
international firefighter union ad they
had had me saying that firefighters
don't really have all that much to do
and and then they cut to a clip of
firefighters pulling you know dying
people out of buildings and it I mean I
couldn't stop laughing and and the
reason is they have nothing left other
than emotionalism and using me on an ad
I had a firefighter union guy he comes
in when I worked at the register he was
furious he wanted a correction and my
editor
like you know don't mention the word
correction in front of an editor she's
like what's up and the guy says you
Steve reported that we were paid for
sleeping and that's not true and what
isn't she goes were paid while sleeping
correction yeah correction granted right
I gladly did that correction so I
couldn't wait and anyway it it's a
little funny but it's pretty sad I mean
when we look I remember thats tahsil
show john stossel he shows it shows what
what public employees are doing to the
public services and this is where we
make common cause with honest
progressives granted that might be an
oxymoron but I know a few he shows a
sheet of paper eight and a half by 11
with little boxes and arrows showing
what it takes to fire a teacher right
and the LA Times in fact did a did a
whole front page series on saying that
you the LAUSD doesn't even try to fire
incompetent teachers but if you're can
you know if you're accused credibly
accused of committing a crime it can
take 12 years they put you in rubber
rooms blah blah blah well anyway stop so
we get to the end of it and the audience
is laughing and then he lets go in for
more sheets fall to the floor now I
could imagine if if I couldn't get rid
of reporters who who were incompetent I
mean what kind of a news service would I
have I mean what think of the areas i
mean in your life where you work how
would you have and this is how we
educators kids I mean Haddix it's scary
so we can't fire them there's not much
accountability i could go on see I don't
have much time left but about some of
the police abuse issues I covered as a
newspaper guy and what I saw it was it
was horrendous and because the union's
stand up for the worst and I wanted to
mention we're talking about the the the
whole thing of the government's
negotiating on both sides of the table
at the local level it's really bad and
in many cases the city employees
negotiating with the unions are members
of the very Union they're negotiating
against now who negotiates on behalf of
the taxpayers
and there the City Council has been
elected with the help of the same unions
what do you think is going to happen
this is how that people always want to
know how it happened well this is how it
happened well you know we weren't paying
attention 911 also was terrible for many
reasons but this was one thing that has
really been harmful during Alma many
salary negotiations with Public Safety
officials since then they refer to 911
and officials don't want to go up
against that but we must confront this
the fact that even Governor Brown is is
proposing something that's that's
perfectly reasonable doesn't go far
enough but it but it's good we have to
deal with current employees I'm not
saying retro actively remove their
pensions but starting tomorrow start
earning at a lower rate like it's
happened in the private sector because
just changes for for new hires that does
not that's not going to fix the whole
problem and the final point is the
unions are going to come come after us
full bore for no matter what for any
minor reform and and I've had union
officials tell me that I'm like why did
you run that campaign you know you
weren't going to win he said because we
wanted to show our members we want to
flex our muscles so we might as well go
for the gusto we may as well go for the
real reform any reform that doesn't take
on the union's head on isn't going to be
anything worth doing thank you very much
Thank You Stephen well we've had a good
good series of talks on public sector
unions we've had Paul with the history
of public sector unions and Charles
emphasizing more of the economics of
public sector unions and now the
politics with Stephen and we have some
time for questions we have perhaps as
much as 12 to 14 minutes for questions
and so why don't we open it up to those
of you in the audience okay
good afternoon and stay on your question
the state who your question is for well
it's not quite a question I want to
bring up a point that Chuck Charlie
mention about unionize and you know it
takes fifty percent plus one person for
a facility or factory to unionize and
that facility of factory has to
represent all work is whether ones join
you union or do not join the union one
point on whatever emphasizes in the
right to work state you do not have to
join your rune in desktop mansion and
they have to represent you but in a nun
right-to-work state you still don't have
during the Union but they're going to
take the dues out of your paycheck
anyway so you'll have no obligation you
have no reasoning that they're going to
take that union dues out of your
paycheck on a nun right-to-work state
thank god I've lived in right-to-work
states I am a retired air traffic
controller if that brings up a point and
I emphasize the word retired not fired I
went through that patco scenario and
I've seen friends turn against me
because I never joined the union and I
figured I had a real good job without a
college education I wasn't going about
to give that up because of these fellow
employees who are late to turn around
the call and thugs try to get me to join
the union in fact I seen him laughing
President Reagan's face he basically
said okay you guys I'll give you 48
hours get the butts back to work or
you're fired they didn't believe them
I've seen 49 out of 58 air traffic
controllers at my facility get fired
they don't believe President Reagan
course like I said I wasn't Union myself
after that I were because it was so
short of controllers I worked overtime
for about a year and a half you know in
government and if no 40 hours this time
I have I work 60 hours a week for about
a year and a half you do the math I
cried all the way to the bank Thank You
least in theory even in Union compulsory
union states you're supposed to be
entitled to a refund of those parts of
the dues that you pay that don't go for
actual organizing and embargoing matters
that the political spending that these
unions do i was actually i'm a member of
the Amalgamated Meat Cutters because I
worked at a supermarket in New York when
I was in high school and in college and
the thing that annoyed me the most about
that was the the propaganda that my dues
were going to support against the Reagan
administration now it's a very difficult
matter to actually recover those non non
economic payments but at least in the
law is you know that's Chuck you might
know this better than I that that's
correct no person who was represented by
a union and who is not a member can be
forced to pay full union dues they have
to pay what is called an agency fee for
the representation services and it's
supposed to be just for representation
services not for anything that the Union
does in politics not even for organizing
that's not a chargeable expense under
the Beck Supreme Court Beck decision in
1988 unions make it as difficult as
possible to you know when people try to
get their money returned and they
understate it and that's why the
paycheck protection is one alternative
to make it an opt-in rather than an
opt-out
yep Jerry go ahead a couple pull okay is
it on okay a couple of observations we
see that the private sector union
membership is declining but Joe addicts
to what extent are they being successful
in getting free trade agreements enacted
that require the other countries to
provide healthcare housing and all the
other things that they have workers have
here in order to raise the cost of doing
business over there and therefore lessen
the desire to move operations overseas
as question number one I think I'd
probably go to mr. Moreno and secondly
why do public the police officers and
firefighters safety officers why do they
get a premium when they are working in
other words they get paid more money
than a counting does but when they
retire they get ninety percent of their
last pay and the poor accountant at the
same time of year in 30 years he only
gets only 65 or 70 percent why is that
and how can we change it on the on the
globalization point there is a lot of
talk from union organizers about that
but the actual prospects of global
organizing a global labor market are
pretty not likely to change things what
they are doing though is a lot of
private sector unions are beginning to
organize in in the public sector there
is a movement to organize for instance
graduate student teaching assistants who
can make some claim to being exploited
but in any case the most active union
organizing them is the United Auto
Workers so you may be a situation where
is one day the majority of united auto
workers unions are not auto workers but
have gone into the growth fields which
for the public sectors after they've
killed their private sector industries
I'd like to comment on one other quirk
in the law that has to do with
private colleges and universities like
Hillsdale the there is a Supreme Court
decision that says faculty at private
colleges and universities our
supervisors / managers and therefore
under the National Labor Relations Act
are not subject to unionization in the
government sector of course that that's
an entirely different body of law but
when it comes to the private sector
higher education faculty union there can
never be mandatory good faith bargaining
with exclusive bargaining agents it's
simply impossible for that to be forced
on a president now a president who's
who's a little weak on the subject like
Larry Arn may may agree may make foolish
least they agree to recognize the union
for the faculty he can do that right but
i'm sure he and any other sensible CEO
of a college university would never we
would never enter into such agreement
therefore they don't have to worry about
unionization of faculty on the question
about public safety mmm elected
officials have decided that you know
first responders because their jobs are
arguably more dangerous than our you
know certainly are in some cases get a
higher amount and then of course the
public safety unions have used that to
to guilt people especially since 911 and
to making the disparity ever bigger and
expanding the categories I always tell
the public safety officials say I argue
with my roofer doesn't get three percent
of 50 and he's got a far more dangerous
job and they don't really like that and
then what they say as well you don't
want sixty-five-year-old cops chasing
down criminals I'm like well in reality
most of those jobs are you know
bureaucratic investigation jobs I'm not
trying to diminish the jobs or anything
it's just that you don't really have
sixty-five-year-old cops chasing down
criminals just like in the newspaper
business we don't have you know
50-something editors chasing down
stories they're the ones at the desk so
you know it's that's I understand the
disparity to a degree but I don't
understand how it's got it's gotten way
out of hand and it's just it's politics
I got a question just out of curiosity
the Bible says in proverbs chapter 24
verse 5 knowledge is power any verse 6
it says when you go to battle you better
have counsel so I'm thinking about
citizens knowledge and Citizens Council
how do we get the government to be
transparent and how do we make how do we
I know the media is the fifth branch of
the government so can you can you
enlighten us and then that too okay Paul
jaleco well I guess that's the Steve
that's your job I mean well actually I
think Karen see and information I think
media is not better i think media
coverage of this issue's fabulous and i
think part of the reason is a lot of
editors are my age they realize say we'd
be retired and living in the Cayman
Islands if I were public employee but
but that it's a it's a wide-open media
world now and they're a lot more and I
think the coverage has been much better
on these issues but it's just
heartbreaking the power of the union's I
mean we can only report on things we
can't make anyone do anything the most
pressing transparency issue as I very
hastily try to explain in my
presentation in government sector
unionism is this bargaining in secret
good faith bargaining is always insecure
the public has no access has no voice
and in that bargaining process of course
the as I said the government unions the
employing bureaucrats have to make
concessions to the government unions or
the door nothing happens that it is that
is the most clandestine way in which
taxpayer burdens are are increased in
this country in my opinion great point
from what I remember covering local
government what would this would always
happen and this way it was done the the
unions would negotiate a deal with the
city it was done in closed session which
was allowed under the Brown Act are open
meetings law because it was a
negotiation they'd come to terms with
the deal they'd send the deal to the
unions still nobody in the public has
yet to be notified even of what the
meeting was about then they come to a
deal everyone would have a deal and then
they would drop it Thursday before the
Tuesday council meeting in a way that
nobody in the right mind would even know
the council meeting comes on Tuesday the
vote happens by Thursday everyone's kind
of realized hey what just happened it's
already law our time is up but we I'd
like to have a hand for our three panels